in the beginning was the word and the
Word was with God and the Word was God
he was in the beginning with God all
things came into being through him and
without him not one thing came into
being what has come into being in him
was life and the life was the light of
all people the light shines in the
darkness and the darkness did not
overcome it there was a man sent from
God whose name was John
he came as a witness to testify to the
light so that all might believe through
him he himself was not the light but he
came to testify to the light the true
light which enlightens everyone was
coming into the world he was in the
world and the world came into being
through him yet the world did not know
him he came to what was his own and his
own people did not accept him but to all
who received him who believed in his
name he gave power to become children of
God who were born not of blood or of the
will of the flesh nor of the will of man
but of God and the word became flesh and
lived among us and we have seen his
glory the glory as a father's only Son
full of grace and truth
John testified to him and cried out this
was he of whom I said he who comes after
me ranks ahead of me because he was
before me from his fullness we have all
received grace upon grace the law indeed
was given through Moses grace and truth
came through Jesus Christ no one has
ever seen God it is God the only Son who
is close to the Father's heart who has
made him known
David is great to be with you for what I
hope will be a great set of
conversations about one of my favorite
acts the fourth gospel
and as you know I come with this text as
someone who's involved with the life of
the church and try to read it for the
church but also try to read it as a
document that's coming out of the first
century and I found it all all very
helpful for me to try to understand how
the images the vocabulary they the
motifs the structure of the text reflect
things that are going on in that first
century world as well as some of the
conflicts in the early church and I know
you have a similar approach but you
might want to just say a word or two
about how you come at it
well I share that very much my concern
through the years has been to teach
preaching as well as new Testament so
I'm always concerned with how it texts
meets the needs of the people how it
speaks to a contemporary congregation
but I think as Bible students and as
preachers we lose it if we simply say
here's what the text means to me with no
sense of what it meant in its earlier
context and what it's meant to the life
of the church so for me the excitement
of studying a text like John is that
it's rich in itself and it's rich in its
implications for contemporary faith both
those things yeah certainly one of the
things that I found in my long-term
study of the gospel is it's a
marvelously complex text acceding with
but the more I read it the the greater
depth I find in it I don't think it's
all just in my mind no I think no and
they're new surprises each time that's
part of the and having a conversation
with you that's part of the fun if we've
done a bits and pieces of this but the
pleasure will be all mine ever for a
segment so let's begin with them the
prologue of the gospel I think lots of
people are familiar with it in the
beginning was the word and the Word was
with God and the Word was God and it
goes on in that vein for about 18 verses
and this is a marvelously poetic text I
found then some some aspects off at a
technical poetry and they the way we
think about it and Hebrew Bible terms
that is with parallel phrases stacked up
and then little catch words that build
in a kind of climax all the way through
so it has a poetic quality to it that
invites you into the text in ways that
other Gospels don't and sort of making a
statement about this text that it is a
work of literature in a way that seems
to be a little more sophisticated than
some of the other tags and it's always
been a question to me how that the
prologue relates to the rest
to the gospel because there are points
of fit as well as points of tension
between them I don't know if you found
that no I pulled I'm teaching a class on
John right now in fact with some
students and we've been puzzling about
the fact that in some ways it's very
much a kind of overture like a musical
comedy overture here are the themes of
the main songs we're going to have and
then every once in a while it seems to
wander off into its own world for
example we'll come back to this but the
very keyword Lagos in the beginning was
the word you'd think that that is a word
that we'd recur time after time after
time and it doesn't to the extent that
one might think if that's the very
keyword of the text but I do think the
images that are there I think the sense
of conflict between believers and
unbelievers that's already there the
promise of Christ as being God's great
gift to humankind those themes I think
begin and emerge and stay through the
whole gospel right the light and
darkness the light and dark Eve
yeah and the contrast between Moses and
grace upon grace and now we have Christ
exactly what that contrast is as well as
continuity is something that the text is
going to be playing with right yeah that
text that phrase grace upon grace is an
odd Greek text because most literally
would have said grace instead of grace
and I find myself wondering whether this
means I've always appreciated grace
piled upon grace how much grace can you
get amazing grace and then even more
grace I've wondered sometimes whether
it's saying the gift of Jesus is even
more important than the gift of Moses so
it's a substitute grace not just an ad
in Greece I don't know you puzzled about
that well I've wrestled with that a lot
and one of the things that we'll be
bumping up against throughout our
conversations on the fourth gospel is
this tension between its affirmation of
the the Jewish tradition biblical for
them and that the polemical elements in
it very strong it has some rather nasty
things to say about those who reject
Jesus and labels them as our Jews and
we'll have to think a little bit about
how that language is developing so yeah
there's both continuity and also
discontinuity in that affirmation about
grace upon grace we'll get back to the
long us in just a minute but I want to
think about some of these other points
in the the prologue that elements of
continuity the one thing that's I think
very important in they at the prologue
it's the way it's framed it begins with
the notion of the word and then at the
very end it says something about what
the function of Jesus is
that as Jesus is the one who explains
who the father is
yeah the Greek word is executed yeah the
exit the exegesis is the exit of God so
he's a Bible everybody everywhere every
Bible teachers greatest hopeful but I
think that that captures an important
theme that runs through the whole of the
gospel and the gospel is claiming that
look Jesus is the revealer in some way
that the Christian experience is about a
new revelation of revelation and
continuity with the old but it's a
revelation and that's been one of the
the key problems in understanding the
gospel during the course of the last
century what's the content of that
revelation well the the great scholar of
John's Gospel Rudolf Bultmann who helped
us I think all think about it finally
said the content of the revelation was
the revelation that I reveal that I am
the revealer and then if to believe in
me as revealer is to believe that I
reveal our you've helped me think about
the fact that there are actually more
implications to it than just that but
certainly I think the first thing that
that the word incarnate does is to
reveal that he is the word incarnate and
that life comes through belief in him
and that theme recurs time after time
after time mm-hmm
right so revelation is going to be
something we'll have to worry about
major themes and whether there's some
content - yeah Here I am and then you
mentioned incarnation that's one of the
other key focal points of the prologue
John 1:14 and the word became flesh and
dwelt among us and that evokes that that
certainly evokes the the elements of
continuity and discontinuity that we've
seen because that kind of phrasing as
you know comes from Ben Sira yeah and
the affirmation that the Word of God
dwells in the in Israel as Torah and so
in some ways the gospel is saying Jesus
dwells among us as tall as Torrance -
yeah and yeah as continuity and
describing the same old theme and the
and the idea what that when he dwells
among us he actually Tabernacles among
us
so like the Shekinah for the people of
Israel it does become God's glory
present in human form I think right that
word is very important to skeino Santa
hitched in Stanton
sometimes that's lost in translation
important yeah and then the notion of
incarnation
- that raises another major issue with
the gospel
there's one famous New Testament scholar
of the 20th century who who said that
Jesus is portrayed in this gospel as a
god walking yes of the earth right I
heard him say it those were the four
lectures at Yale and his contention
really was that the gospel is almost doe
setting you know it almost so emphasizes
the deity of Jesus that you forget he's
a human being
and a number of people have reacted
against that and looked to that
particular verse the word became flesh
right and have insisted that what we get
in the fourth gospel really is a very
fleshy Jesus you know that's where
that's one of my great puzzles I've
heard the debate that weather is the
stress he beheld his glory that's case
man's line the heart of it is the glory
barely incarnate and it's just it's just
enough flesh so that the glory doesn't
totally blind us by its glorious but not
enough flesh to make Jesus fully human
and there are moments we'll get to the
passion narrative there are moments in
the passion narrative where he doesn't
Jesus does not see him as human as
bereft as pained as he doesn't listen
optic Gospels on the other side he weeps
he has friends he relates to people he
cares he gets angry he gets angry so I
think Kate Saban overstated the case the
case however is this is not this this is
not the same Jesus we'd know if we had
only Matthew Mark and Luke something new
has come here and I think the prologue
is some gives us some clues to what's
the difference about that yeah you
raised another fascinating issue the
relationship between the fourth gospel
and the synoptic Gospels because on the
surface it looks so very different
serving the voice of Jesus is so
different he gives these long years
sounds like Woody Allen and the Gospel
of Mark and he sounds like one of us in
professor I was going to go to that
first the second thing first I said he
sounded like us good let's go so there's
that difference this there's a
similarity in the overall structure but
a lengthier time when Jesus is a time
longer speeches no miracles are always
the occasion for sermons never people
don't just jump up and down and say
wonderful as they do in the
mmm-hmm and innocence of the passion
right well that's that's an important
one we want to get back to that and then
there were some episodes that had seen
me leave this place to the cleansing of
the temple yeah in the synoptic that
takes place too at the end of the
accountant John it takes place right at
the beginning very beginning of ministry
so will the real proper sequence stand
out very difficult glory you mentioned
that's another one of these themes
that's announced in the the gospel and
the prologue to the gospel of them runs
all the way through and we'll have to
come back and try to unpack that
especially when we come to the The
Passion of Absolution account and it
will be tied in with this issue of
Christology one other thing that I
wanted to mention on the Christological
issue you know we we are so often think
of the prologue and its affirmation
about the incarnation of Jesus and do so
in the light of our reading of the other
Gospels especially Matthew and Luke very
much so we think of the incarnation is
focusing on the birth of Jesus
but it's interesting and the both got no
birth story no birth story and some ways
the most interesting thing to be said
about the prologue is it's so different
from any others starting but then Jesus
Jesus begins at the beginning of time
and then comes on the scene as a
full-grown man with not this
transitional Matthew and Luke stuff
northings absolutely right also the
other life we look back at it on is is
the full flown church council decisions
of the 4th and 3rd century about what
incarnation is and and the John doesn't
yet know about the two natures or
substance or all those things in which
this letter gets perhaps properly
interpreted but I think we sometimes
load more metaphysics onto it than he's
ready to carry yeah certainly John was
the foundational document for all of the
fourth and fifth century christological
and Trinitarian theologians but they're
reading some they're reading something
back out of their own countries right so
we have to abstract from that just a
little bit it is important though to
understand something about this notion
of the law God that is coming from you
know one one of the ways in which I try
to think about the dynamics of the
prologue as it is coming out of that
wisdom tradition right that begins in
the book of Proverbs right and talks
about the wisdom as the handmaid
God and the helpmeet of God there from
the at the moment of creation taking
delight and the children of men and then
picked up in Ben Sira that we already
mentioned where wisdom comes into Torah
and then also when the wisdom of Solomon
written probably into the first century
BC for a century AD that gives a kind of
Greek twist to the same notion and talks
about wisdom as that in which there is a
Ponomarev aids all things and comes into
the souls of man in every generation and
makes them Friends of God and prophets I
have this long tradition about thinking
of the the wisdom the Spirit of God and
then that's picked up in a very
interesting guy Fido of Alexandria
Jewish interpreter of Scripture someone
trained in Greek philosophy as well as
scripture and he calls this Sophia this
wisdom log on the other word yeah and
something of that background I think is
going on and in John I think yes Emily I
do you think I'm puzzled about whether
father was the link my theory of the
year which is just because we have to
have theories of the year or we could
have to stop talking about this stuff by
theory of the year is that this is
deeply deeply influenced by the Sophia
the wisdom speculation and that John has
that as his background the sense that
this creative power was with God from
the beginning and provides the blueprint
by which God creates the world and the
miracle in Jesus is that that divine
wisdom is now present among us but he's
got a problem and you're gonna shoot
this down and I've got to go back and
take it back with my whole class the
problem is that he knows this incarnate
person was not as Sophia usually is
female incarnate but male incarnate so
he tries to find a good male noun to get
ignored the same idea and voila lagos
male right well in that I think you're
right all good and it's worth exploring
because it also opens up another
dimension of thinking about this text
and that's the way in which it uses
gender categories yeah and here at least
the Evangelist who is anticipated by
Philo who has a similar image so similar
set of issues
he doesn't doesn't want to affirm the
femininity of God because it doesn't
doesn't it's not compatible
either you know okay yeah you know it's
it's probably a longer and more
respectable tradition in the Jewish
world to think about that Verena mention
of God in the Greek but in the Greek
world where there's a strict hierarchy
of genders external God has to be
masculine spiritual has to be masculine
or ungenerous yeah so there's a lot of
gender play going on here and I you know
John is aware of this yeah I'm sure
because women play a very important role
in the fourth cos they do and we're
going to be bumping up against a couple
of them they Samaritan we're at the well
America and Mary Magdalene Martha Martha
yeah and I know some contemporary
critics are divided over this are they
playing a significant role that affirms
they're very much devoted their value or
is it something rather along the lines
of what you have scale so some more -
yeah I do think that that that John has
his own spin on the tradition but he has
a kind of irreducible tradition that if
you have to have Christ crucified
however it does setec he may be and
there is a resurrection even though you
don't quite know what to do with it and
there is an encouraging our he can't
absent himself from the story entirely
and part of the the fun for me is to see
what I think is his blending of his own
very significant different reading of
the duration without letting the
tradition go mm-hmm yeah one of the
notions that I've used I think you're
quite right on that he's bound in some
ways by that by the story but also
treats it very independently very
independently right he has his own mind
and that gets back to that technical
issue of whether John is is using the
synoptic Gospels or whether he's picking
up some traditions that are independent
of them my own take on that and it
probably is a minority taken the
scholarly world is that he does know
mark and he does know Luke but feels in
no way around by them I think he knows
mark yeah I think he heard market his
mother's knee or something like that and
said remember that feeding of the 5000
story I can do something with that just
yeah or he heard of that the Christian
synagogue around the synagogue does like
that preacher like something yeah so I
think he knows those tax is not bound by
them and treats them with a kind of
sovereign freedom
and and sort of tweaks the form I've
used the term genre-bending rather than
gender bending genre-bending to try to
get at this the sense that John is a
very sophisticated user of literary
materials he knows the way in which the
Jesus story has been told and he's going
to tell it better I think that's it I
want to pick up your genre gender
blending bending thing because it one
fine article too I think that that you
pick up on one of John's qualities which
he's a punster
and he's a punster with a purpose and
that one way to read John is to read the
double meanings that words have and
that's true in the prologue to where it
says the light shines in the darkness
and then the Greek word can mean the
darkness has not understood it or can
mean the darkness has not overcome it
and lots of ink is spilled about which
does he mean and I think he means both
mm-hmm I think that that he depends on
the ability of his hearers or readers to
know that words mean more than one thing
and that he can play on that and I think
he does that here and he'll do it again
when we look at Nicodemus I think yeah
that's a very important element of the
Gospel as a whole the way in which the
deeper meanings of things are probed
through they do blunt Andris that are
the texts and it it it it raises the
larger strategy of the text of dealing
with irony and we're going to see that
in Nicodemus you're going to see it and
the woman at the well where the
characters in the text don't seem to
know what they shoe exactly and it's
stuff that we know and partly because
we've read this prologue but then you
begin to wonder is is this clever author
also doing something visa vie us
actually telling us that maybe we're not
getting where do we stand in the story
are we are we smart Jesus are we
struggling Nicodemus are we got it all
put together Jesus are we woman at the
whale putting it together piece by piece
and I my own bias which we'll see more
and more is that he cleverly finds a way
of involving us not so much as Jesus as
Jesus conversation partner that in those
dialogues we we follow along with the
other person to try to find out I need
to I need to push you on the NRK
business mm-hmm clearly an echo of
Genesis
in the beginning in the beginning now
it's not in the beginning God now it's
in the beginning the word this word is
and the Greek is a little odd because we
we make it in the the word was God
it actually says God was the word and it
doesn't directly say that the Word was
with God I'm one of my friends gave me
the Tyndall translation last week and
Tyndall one of the first people to
translate this into English in the 14th
century says the word was ask God which
doesn't work very well in modern English
but it's closer in some ways to the way
the Greek works than are with God what
what's what's going on here what's the
claim about Jesus
eternal status that's being made in this
prologue because I think that's
important for how we understand his
humanity - yeah just to emphasize those
couple of syntactical or semantic
elements that you a pointing to that the
first two words in RK don't really
translate as in the beginning right but
it's precisely the same way in which the
book of Genesis exactly which is a
literal translation of the Hebrew
brother sheet exactly and then the
preposition and the longest was Pross
talked on it's a word that means toward
yeah it almost suggests a kind of
dynamic relationship which is
interesting in terms of one of the
possible backgrounds of all of this let
me go back to that that might help try
to unpack what what kind of affirmation
is being made here I want to go back to
Philo when to the wisdom of Solomon
because I think they point us in the
direction that we need to go and order
to understand what this lagos is all
about that lagos a word language his
stuff that was common in Greek
philosophy since the pre-socratic since
Heraclitus Heraclitus talked about the
kind of rationality the kind of
mysterious rationality that was inherent
in all things and governed all things
that held things that were opposites in
some sort of tense of unity Stoics who
were a major stream of greek
philosophers in the Hellenistic period
from the fourth century on picked up on
this language and they used it to
describe the kind of fundamental
principle that holds all things together
the best way of understanding stoicism
I'd like to tell my students is to
remember they the Star Wars movies
and the notion of the force force
because that was the force that's right
forces with you right
the Stoics had a notion that the world
that we inhabit is a uniform a
materialist world era that had two
dimensions an active and a passive we
might in contemporary physical terms
think of matter and energy so they're
energetic rational force they called God
and they said this really holds all
things together Jews picked up on this
wisdom of Solomon knows that an ocean
Philo knows it - very well
but he also links it with another notion
because Philo was a guy who brought
together platonic as well as stoic
traditions and Plato as you remember had
the notion that there's an ideal world
that's quite separate from this world of
phenomena yes material world that we
live in and experience and it's that
ideal world that gives the meaning and
rationality and coherence to the world
in which we'd if we know what we know
because there were those ideas or forms
out there Plato always had the problem
of how you made the connection between
that ideal world and the material world
he also had another problem that in his
myth of creation he has a god figure the
Demiurge who looks at these ideas and
tries to get them into the world of
matter so there's something above God
in Plato's right right Philo comes along
for a century
falafel Asafa caleche exegete he wants
to read his Genesis in a way that is
compatible with contemporary
philosophical and scientific theories
and he knows there were problems in
doing so so he blends them all together
and he blends Plato and the Stoics and
solves the Plato Plato's first problem
by putting the ideas in the mind of his
God and then saying that when God speaks
as he does in Genesis he utters his word
his word which were originally into his
mind as thought and when he does so
rationality and meaning and truth given
to this universe that's the log on that
I think is the world that our evangelist
voguing that's good in talking about who
Jesus is from us and I think we can be
sure that that's the case because
Christian theologians
in the second century picked up this
language of the logos and tried to use
it to articulate how it is that Jesus is
somehow with God from all eternity and a
human being at the same time right and
they picked up the stoic notion of the
thoughts and the mind of God being
expressed as God's speech and his
creative act so I think that's the
alternate background that of course
introduces another another interesting
tension in this text that was there and
that the Jewish world of which John is a
product tension between the universal
and the particular I if God is there
through God's reason and love and grace
in all of the world then why is this
provider necessary in the Torah yeah
oranges I mean Jesus yeah yeah let me
come back and I just want to circle back
to the to the file on ik and the logos
that's all very rich and very helpful I
also think that if this is written for
an audience that knows something of
Hebrew Scripture that they're just a
couple of kind of obvious things that
come to mind to them that we mean is as
you said NRK echoes the way they heard
the Genesis story if I'm sitting down in
church or in a conversation and somebody
says brace sheet NRK in the beginning I
begin to think in the beginning God if
what we get is in the beginning Lagos
which is both an echo and a correction
and and the other thing is as you quite
rightly pointed out if you look at the
Genesis story the first thing that God
does is to speak devar so to say that in
the beginning was the word used to say
all the things about Lagos and Philo
it's also to say if you just read the
story you'll notice the first thing that
shows up next to God is this word God
speaks let there be light and there was
life so it's it's a both a Midrash on
the text I think and a philosophical
reading of it and that's part of the
richness of it now we come to the top
level how do you do the general in the
specific and and one place that comes to
comes to bear is in the midst of this
long beautiful poetic introduction the
people who try to kind of parse out the
poetry from the editing editing suggest
that the that the place where John the
Evangelist comes and fixes the poem it's
about John the Baptist
and you suddenly have in the midst of
all this speculation about the way the
world fits together there was a man
named John sent from God and suddenly
were landing in history and in a
particular story right there there's a
sense of paradox and the the sense of
paradox is something I think John also
inherits from his philosophical as well
as from perhaps his Jewish savvy antral
background that is that truth can be
expressed in its highest and most potent
form when it doesn't seem to cohere at
the level of surface meaning and so the
paradox of seeing the glory of God
revealed in a dead body on a cross
yeah huge it's part of it yeah yeah so
he embraces the particular embraces and
pushes it to its its logical extreme if
not beyond it Hara and I think in doing
so he's picking up an impulse that's
there and lots of early Christian
theology and one of the things that I've
often worried about is is whether John
knows Paul I know I think so well I
don't know I'm not going to go to the
barricades but at least on this point
where where Paul has a theology of the
cross you know Christ in him crucified
John does a similar narrative mode so
yeah the particularity is something that
he does embrace and will will force yeah
no I think it's I think that's a huge
part of the paradox I think part of the
paradox is that eternity comes into time
that the general in particular are both
true when I when I talk to students
about preaching which is related to this
in some ways I say don't talk to me in
generalizations about the way God enters
the world show it to me find a place
where it comes incarnate and and long
discussions about what's wrong with the
world that say war famine plague
disaster are not nearly as impressive as
I know a woman who lost her son in the
same way I think that just just
dramatically speaking poetically
speaking word language Lagos language
light language some point has to get
pinned down to this particularity of the
fleshly person who talks with a woman at
the well heals the blind man gets
crucified the the theological power
almost demands a kind of particularities
to be powerful right mamani of your
calling attention to that
Pras and ambach relationship and the way
in which John time after time we'll talk
about the encounters that Jesus has and
it's in those encounters that that's
something significant emerges oh
absolutely
in the power of this the power of this
gospel for me is that interesting
combination which becomes so crucial to
Christian theology which is that the
very god of very God is yet and how he
we use the waffle words somehow present
let's say present and the particularity
of this man and of his story and of his
relationships to other people and that's
still after all the centuries I think an
astonishing claim mm-hmm yes indeed one
of the ways in which that happens I
think is through the affirmation of the
spirit but somehow one is born of God
and that'll take us to our next story
story will come too soon